well keeps me up at night stress from
blogging keeps me up at night but what
keeps me up at night is how to make
feminists saying specifically a bit but
also just kind of the online world
better for feminists and and more
effective I think you know after you're
doing this for a bunch of years and I've
been at it for five it becomes more
difficult every day because the more
readers you have the more criticism you
get and especially when you're doing
feminist work and you're doing political
work the more hatred you get also and
just trying to balance the negativity
with you know the reality that you are
making positive change in people's lives
and trying to remember that